just
died on me as well just be a few minutes
um welcome to the uh meeting of the
north established district council's
cabinet it's the
uh 28th of january 2021
it's 4 30 or 4 35 um
we'll we'll get uh started straight away
with the uh with the agenda so
the first item is uh apologies for
absence
uh non-received chair non-received
thanks alan
uh the next item is declarations of
interest are there any uh that any
members wish to declare
no i can see shaking of heads okay and
then we come to the minutes of the last
meeting held on the 17th of december
have we all had a chance to uh review
them and
can confirm that they're a true and
accurate record
i can have a mover i'll move it if
someone's a second
carolyn thank you all those in favor
thank you very much and then we come to
the
visitor economy strategy so i'll hand
over to council reddick
who's going to talk us through uh talk
us through that paper
yeah i know you've all had the
opportunity now to uh look at the
digital economy strategy just to
reiterate that you know that
we do recognize the importance of the
tourism and visitor common strategy
across the district we've been working
on this for some time
and just for background information
we've not had a strategy before for the
visual economy
and um i believe that whilst we're
looking at it initially is this become
more urgent because of the pandemic and
because
you know at the end of the day we have
300 plus businesses
in this sector and a lot of businesses
that support it um
2 000 jobs and 147 million to our
economy
and whilst we haven't got uh some of the
prestigious
tourist attractions that some parts of
davos should have we do
i believe have our own unique selling
point and that is
encapsulated in the vision that we know
we are a destination between
the peak district in town city um we
have experiences to offer
and i think that we're in it's quite an
enviable position
and i hope you all agree with the
strategy that we've
developed with the help of councillor um
councillor alan powell and so to promote
the district to visitors
both day tripping and overnights we want
to try and create an all-round
digital economy in the district improve
the skills of business owners and their
employees which will fit into our growth
and skill strategy too
and to develop this to offer experiences
so i would
highly recommend recommendations 6.1 to
6.4 and i move that
to this cabinet thank you council renick
uh i'm very happy to second are there
any other comments that any members wish
to make or any questions
no i think this is a very good paper um
really pleased to see it brought forward
i know it's taken a lot of work from
uh from officers within within within
your portfolio and
jill's uh team but it's definitely a
very good piece of work and
look forward to seeing it uh being
implemented so
um if there's unless there's any further
comments we'll move to the vote
all those in favor
that's carrie thank you very much and
then the next paper is the
uh another pay-per-view council run it
which is the
employment and skills strategy so i'll
hand back over to you
thank you and again i know you've all
had opportunities to to
um look at this paper and discuss with
me um
has been amended slightly and just just
to make clear whilst
it's not a statute of duty um for us to
deliver skills
we absolutely see the importance of
actually trying to support
local residents in business to upskill
again we've been looking at this
strategy for some time
and the pandemic has actually increased
the need and accelerated
our determination to make sure we have a
key role in in
supporting both residents and businesses
uh again
you've all had a chance to read it and i
would hope
you would agree to move the
recommendations
thanks very much council renick uh
again i'm very happy to second uh very
welcome piece of work as you say it's
not a
necessarily a statutory duty for us but
it's it's very good that we're taking a
clear role
uh within this and aligning ourselves to
the wider
uh employment and skills strategy from
the the d2n2 left and
and of course came to council and other
relevant partners as well so it's good
to see that we
we have this this document and obviously
can work towards achieving that
uh the ancient ambitions that it sets
out so thank you very much again
for all the work on that yeah
yeah and part of the process is is that
we've done a lot of more now and
um work with with the d2m2 obviously the
with the dcc and um it's about aligning
our strategies and actually
um we are aligned in all our ambitions
even some of the government ambitions
so i think this is put in the right
direction and hopefully we can
improve the skills of them and
particularly the aspirations
in in our area i think for me a real
turning point was
from the clay cross surveys when the
aspirations aren't there we can do more
to support that
and i would like to thank um for both
these reports um
jill and her team for for
providing these and all the work that's
gone into developing them
absolutely yeah reiterate that and
completely agree with the um the
aspiration um sort of issue we know from
the
uh social mobility uh commission report
from a couple of years ago
that our area is one uh in which social
mobility is a is a problem an aspiration
i think is a key
key part of that and we've really got to
drive that up to uh
to try and improve on our position so
thank you uh
once again for that um it's been moved
i've seconded it
um all those in favor
[Music]
brilliant thank you very much everyone
uh and then we come to the
uh medium term financial plan and i'll
hand over to council parking
thank you very much chair um
right so uh as you'll be aware no doubt
uh there have been um some unusual
circumstances in the last
12 months it's been a very challenging
budget setting
process uh the pandemic leading to
uncertainty
surrounding uh the proposed national
settlement for 21-22
and it was released around the 17th of
december and was
effectively a further rollover of the
2015
so um it also included a series of
measures
specifically targeted at assisting with
the financial challenges
that the council faces but also
other people i guess you know we we've
been very very lucky
in in the fact that uh the central
government has been
uh so generous in its uh support of
councils um during the covet period
and some of the challenges we've been
facing a
three-year spread of collection fund
losses
support where the ability uh
the ability to levy council tax and
business rates has reduced
election rates uh reduced um
this is known as the local taxation
income compensation scheme
so that's been uh that's that's been
announced a continuation of the
income compensation scheme for lost fees
and charges
uh into quarter one of 21 22 helps us
with the uh with the with the um
other services that we that we charge
for such as leisure that of course has
been
closed uh and a final trench of covered
grant to ease financial pressures
so uh a one-off lower tier services
grant has also been
blessed our way um the rollover of the
2015 settlement for a further year
means that the changes expected from a
spending review
um we anticipated being negative changes
won't now affect the 21 budget and 2021
budget
which removes um well the majority of
the budget pressures we perceived
before and
those that were identified in last
year's mtfp this means that
along with the covered mentions measures
mentioned before
uh you'll be glad to know that a
balanced budget can be set for this year
uh however it is fully expected that uh
the spending review will inform the 2022
budget etc etc
so um whilst we can
um whilst we can set a balanced budget
the general fund budget can be set for
21.22 the savings targets in few years
obviously remain challenging uh and
a large a large number of variables are
set therein
so um you know we can only uh
i guess the uh financial stargazing of
uh
uh of the experts and uh helping us to
uh to try and predict what will happen
in the future is very difficult
but uh the key thing is to maintain the
momentum and growth and transformation
agenda
uh and this along with the robust budget
management across all service areas will
be a priority in 2021
um as in previous years uh
an upper limit has been set for council
tax increases nationally
uh and this year as in previous years is
set to
1.99 or five percent whichever is the
greater
um so from uh
so this year as in previous years uh is
set at 1.99 percent
of five percent but um we're proposing
an increase of one point nine
five percent i.e three pound seventy
and one d four twenty one slash twenty
two
uh we've not identified major pressures
in the hra account
uh and uh and the national rent setting
guidance has been followed
as we have done as a council for quite
some time
at 1.5 percent um
so i think uh from that i'd like to move
the recommendations in 6.1 to 6.13 in
the report
thank you uh council parking are there
any
any other comments or questions from
cabinet members
councillor kenyon just a comment really
um
i think uh we read in the the news about
the state of
other councils and we hear numbers how
large numbers of them
are not not made able to balance their
budgets
and i think it's a testament to the way
uh the finances of this council have
been managed very prudently and
tough decisions have been made along the
way and as my portfolios leisure
certainly the the government's decisions
to support that sector
have been extremely welcome and uh
i think it's uh it's it's really
very pleasing that we are in a position
to set a balanced budget
uh and uh have come through the current
year
as uh so well so yeah it's uh i think
it's uh
it's very good thank you paul i can
assure you it's um
it's all down to the skills of our chief
financial officer and
uh and uh and the team behind him
yes brilliant thank you councillor
kenyon
uh yeah just to echo what uh what counts
the kenyan encounter
so i think this demonstrates a very
significant level of
support from the government which is
very welcome um you know
it's not only supported local councils
it supported the whole of society
and and the business world as well
through uh through an
extremely difficult time but it is very
much welcome
it doesn't take us quite out of the uh
out of the water in terms of the longer
term there are clearly some challenges
that we face as a council but it
certainly is
has helped us this year and arguably
to a degree next year as well and just
on the council tax rises as councillor
parking has said we are
we are acutely aware of the need to
balance our own needs as a local
authority with
with the uh with the pockets of our our
residents
who have clearly been for a very hard
time uh themselves and i think that
we've set a
uh an appropriate level there that that
has hopefully met that balance we could
have gone higher as councillor parking
said we could have gone
uh to five pound on a bandy which would
have been about two point
six percent increase i believe so 1.95
is a is a modest increase um and
and will help both to sustain the
services that we deliver whilst also not
uh hitting the pockets of our residents
too hard
so i think this is a this is a very good
budget and i'm very happy to
to second the recommendations as council
parkins
uh proposed um any other comments from
anyone else
jane is there anything you'd like to add
just one minor point chad if i could
just update you on
um items 1.20 and 1.21 which is to do
with the
local taxation income compensation
scheme which is a really snappy name
the detail is out on that it's not quite
as lucrative as we
first thought it was going to be in
terms of the 75
compensation but i think it is a fair
scheme
it basically reflects what we could bill
as opposed to what we could collect
the three year spreads dealing with the
collection element
and we're actually in a quite good
position with regards to council tax
and business rates isn't as bad as we
first thought it would be in terms of
what we could bill
not what we could collect so so it's not
quite as lucrative but i don't think
it's affecting us too badly i just
wanted to update you on that because the
report suggested it was going to be
more generous than it has
thanks um i'm just conscious that
um council parking i think moved the
first set of recommendations presumably
we're able to take them on
on block is that okay uh
i have to see sarah nodding and alan
nodding okay lovely so we'll
we'll vote on them on block then so all
those
in favor
probably that carried thank you very
much and then we come back to the
agenda i think believe the next item is
urgent items of which there are none
and then i therefore move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined as
defined in part one
of schedule 12a of the local government
act 1972.
um if we can um end the
live session thank you everyone for
joining us
you